if there's one thing that watching
Netflix is the king taught me is that
the only thing scarier than medieval
battles are these haircuts
yes David me shows the King starring
Timothy sha'lame and King Ramses is a
beautifully shot and directed look at
one of history's greatest warrior Kings
England's King Henry the fifth now you
may be asking yourself think story why
does this ending need to be explained
you won now white I mean he fought some
battles won what is there to know
part of what makes the King fascinating
is Henry's journey how even though he
had absolute power the manipulation and
pressure surrounding and shaping his
decisions made it seem at times like he
had none and there's no better
encapsulation of this than the final
scene between him and William chief
justice we'll get to that in a bit
following the victorious Battle of
Agincourt in 1415 in which the English
defeated Edward Cullen and his army of
Twilight fans
Henry engaged in a months-long
negotiation with King Charles the six of
France in relinquish and control over
the French Kingdom this led to Henry
marrying Charles's daughter Catherine of
Valois it's only when Henry talks to
Catherine about the assassination
attempt against him the same
assassination that spurred Henry to
retaliate and take over France that he
learns the truth the French never sent
the assassin someone within his own
ranks did but before we get to that we
need to understand where Henry started
from started from the bottom now we're
in the beginning of the film he's
portrayed as a drunk womanizer with no
ambitions of taking over his Father's
throne in fact there's no evidence to
suggest he was like this at all his
supposed riotous youth is most likely
the result of Shakespeare who betrayed
him as such in his plays but casting him
like this makes for good character
development as we'll see Henry's
character changed throughout the course
of the film well in the movie he's seen
as a drunk it's his pragmatism and
compassion in the face of war that sets
him apart from his father at least in
the beginning he so believes his father
is wrong fighting the rebellious Hotspur
he puts his own life on the line to
challenge him in one-on-one combat
whoever wins decides the battle saving
countless lives
this selflessness
juxtaposed with Henry's brother Thomas
after Henry's victory against Hotspur he
says his field was mine it was to mark
my Dominion Thomas doesn't care at all
about the countless lives in blood that
was to be shed he only cares for his own
glory Henry on the other hand even
knowing he won't be king put his life on
the line it's when Henry becomes King
however that things start to change he's
no longer a drunk womanizer but on the
same token he's started to move slowly
away from being that strong moral
compass and that selflessness he's had
is starting to be manipulated by
external events around him
the first test comes in the form of a
ball a supposed present from the
delphine of France it's a cruel joke
suggesting the king to be a boy who
still plays with toys a gesture which
would make other Kings march off to
battle to defend their honor
not so with Henry even though he is
recommended to retaliate by his advisers
when this fails to provoke England to
war a new plot is devised an
assassination attempt is foiled twisting
Henry's arm to march on France leading
to their eventual victory at the Battle
of Agincourt during this time Henry's
compassion wanes he orders Falstaff to
kill the prisoners which when he refuses
almost ends up in killing his closest
friend and confidant don't dis about you
right here with my own hand
as his grip on power crumbles so too
does that young compassionate King to be
we saw in the beginning which leads us
to Henry's conversation one may even
liken it to an interrogation of his
future wife Catherine of Valois he asks
her about the assassination attempt and
she iterates that neither his father nor
his brother were the ones to order it in
fact she was in the room when her father
received a message accusing him of the
plot seeing his reaction of laughter at
the farcical claim Henry believes her to
be true therefore making the person
behind the plot someone within his inner
circle he interrogate slore Chief
Justice William asking him how much land
he sought to gain if England were to
conquer France a number he does not know
off the top of his head
Henry presses further asking him how he
came about knowing of this assassination
plot but his lies are easily seen
through that
Chief Justice confesses his part in the
plot saying that it was for the Kings
own good giving you what you wanted boy
am i all Henri wanted was peace but it
came at the costs of thousands of lives
not to mention Henry killing his own
cousin who he thought involved in the
assassination plot this is hope pieces
for it is forged in victory but victory
at the cost of war is never what Henry
wanted his entire conquest in France was
a manipulation
Henry had unwillingly become what he
hated most his father who lust for
conquest when William gets on his knees
to profess Henry's greatness he's
brutally stabbed and killed he is shown
no compassion this is all done before
the eyes of a child a symbol of
innocence Henry then visits Catherine
asking for only one thing from her that
she always speaks to him clear and true
the betrayal of the chief justice
someone who was supposed to speak clear
and true has made Henry wary if he's
going to embark on marriage with her he
needs her to promise this he longs for
truth and clarity which catherine says
she will give him it is said that both
Catherine and Henry loved each other in
real life however there's no evidence to
support that Henry murdered his chief
justice after finding out his
involvement in an assassination plot
that's the art of adapting a real
historical character into a film
adaptation you have to stretch facts in
order to create captivating character
arcs and structural plots
well the ending may not be entirely
accurate the movie isn't so much about
its ending but Henry's journey as a
character touching on themes of what it
means to be strong and what it means to
be a king Henry would go on to rule
until 14 22 roughly seven years after
the Battle of Agincourt paving the way
for more internal struggle within
England and the eventual victory of the
Hundred Years War by France I hope you
enjoyed this video please Knight me by
giving it a like and subscribing I have
more videos coming out every week you
can also follow me on Twitter at think
storyline
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much